Thanks so I'm going to tell you a little
bit of work that we've done in my lab
and one of the goals of our lab is
really to try to help researchers
conduct science in the way that doctor
sent your e talks about basically to
look at all the publicly available data
and to pull new information out of it
and new hypotheses out of it that you
might not get through another approach
and because we want to really focus on
the new we're going to try to do this in
a way where we're not focusing on on
prior biology so we're going to try to
have an unsupervised algorithm that can
mine these really noisy publicly
available data so if you learned things
the same way that I learned things you
would know that this is actually
probably an impossible question
essentially how do I have an
unsupervised algorithm they can pull
sort of biological consistency out of
data but ignore sort of batch and lab
and all these other effects that that
could otherwise confound an unsupervised
analysis so fortunately we have students
and our students don't always know that
things are impossible and so this is the
student in my lab gia tan who actually
you know went sort of took this project
on and ran with it and so the the talk
that i'm going to give is basically the
story of that work and so i'm going to
tell you how we're taking this sort of
machine learning approach and then
extending it to try to identify
biological networks that are perturbed
in an experiment and this is like we
hope us basically giving biologists the
sled that they need to go exploring and
all their publicly available data so
when Gio is starting in my lab it was
right around the time that some
researchers from google we're trying to
find what are the recurrent patterns in
online videos and so I assume in this
audience probably everyone has actually
if you haven't read this paper you've
probably at least read a new york times
article about the paper but does anyone
want to hazard a guess at what computers
might see if they looked at 10 million
images hats yeah so in other audiences
sometimes no one knows yeah so they see
something that looks like this which you
know as humans we can look at this and
we can recognize it as a cat so what are
the cat and biology and how do we get at
them this is the technique that gia
developed it's heavily based on the
denoising auto encoders that are used
other fields like image processing and
we call this this technique here
analysis using denoising auto encoders
of gene expression or adage basically
what you do is you start with your gene
expression data so in this case we have
samples here so this is each gene in a
sample and this is red green coded
fortunately it doesn't really matter
what it is but so this would be low high
and so we have each sample and then what
we do is we add random noise to it just
by dropping out the information for four
randomly selected genes in random
samples and this gives us this corrupted
expression vector and then we train a
neural network to recover basically the
the input data so the data before we
added noise and what we found this is
that what we get out of this is a really
nice mapping to a lot of biological
features in the data that we care about
so for instance this is microbial data
so we get things like growth rate and
strain and oxygen levels in which the
microbes were cultured and and so we've
been really happy with this type of
approach for these data that seems
really robust to the types of noise that
we see in gene expression data when I
present this in front of computational
audiences I often get asked so why in
the world would you use an unsupervised
deep learning style method like why not
just go with the supervised
classification approach because that's
that's essentially what everyone does
and you know we get amazing
classification and I want to go back to
sort of our initial question which was
that we really wanted to extract the
biology that we might not know to look
for so we really wanted to to only focus
on methods that were unsupervised it was
also convenient that while we were
trying to get this paper through peer
review Lagoon Benji Owen Hinton so three
pioneers in deep learning published this
paper where they also highlight that
they think unsupervised learning might
be an interesting application area you
know was kind of where the field started
and then the field has moved on to
supervise and so it's nice to hear that
they also think that that will be moving
back towards towards unsupervised
approaches and so I just want to
introduce you a little bit to the data
that that we've been looking at so this
is the publicly available data have no
idea why random squares are missing up
in the corner here I know why these are
missing so it's noise yeah
so this is apparently random noise on
the PowerPoint presentation about random
noise yes so so each square on here
represents a thousand gene expression
measurements that are publicly available
so a thousand different samples so right
now I when I wrote the abstract I was
hoping there would be two million
publicly available samples by the time
of this conference it turns out there's
not there's 1.97 so we're quite close to
two million publicly available gene
expression samples and for this work
we're going to focus on this square here
so this is a thousand samples and these
aren't just any thousand samples so it's
basically the complete collection of
gene expression data for pseudomonas
aeruginosa this is a microbe that's an
opportunistic human pathogen it causes
very difficult to clear are impossible
to clear infections and individuals with
cystic fibrosis and just to introduce
you a little bit more to this tiny box
and tiny window into into gene
expression there's actually a hundred
different experiments here so if you
think of an experiment as something that
an investigator did and analyzed
probably with the differential
expression analysis published a paper on
and uploaded to geo array express that's
basically you know there's about a
hundred of those here and they come from
many different labs we tried to quantify
the number of labs but it turns out to
be you can't just use the the contact
information associated with the sample
because different people upload from the
same lab so we don't have an exact count
on this but but at least tens of labs
and so so when we applied the the adage
approach to these data I'm just going to
give you a quick sort of idea of what
the result is like so first to introduce
you to this when we build these models
what we end up with is for any given
neuron so here this blue circle is a
neuron in the neural network we get a
set of high weight gene so each of these
is a gene measured in one sample and the
highway genes are essentially shown here
with these thick edges and it turns out
that this tends to follow a normalish
distribution it has some some slightly
different properties but for all intents
and purposes you can think of it a
little bit like a normal distribution
and through a fair amount of work gia
found that a lot of the genes that are
contributing most signal to the nodes
are actually these high weight genes
which is not surprising right this is
going to be a multiplication operation
so the things that are multiplied
a higher amount are probably also the
things that would have the most impact
and if you go back to a set of data sets
that are pretty well known you can
actually say okay given that I know what
I should be changing here where does the
signal come from and she's settled on a
number somewhere around two to three
standard deviations from the mean
basically gives you the genes that kind
of characterize a node it turns out that
these high weight relationships actually
are capture genes pathways reasonably
well we're going to use keg for this
because when we started this work the
gene ontology and pseudomonas was
painfully incomplete there are about 150
to actual annotations of jeans to a
function and that covered 52 genes this
is an organism that has five thousand
genes in its genome so less that it's
actually 5,500 genes so less than one
percent of the genes in the genome had
any sort of gene ontology annotation at
any level of specificity so what we do
here is basically design a quote-unquote
protein function prediction method to
try to predict jeans two pathways but
not with the goal of actually doing a
better job of function prediction but
with the goal of asking does this method
extract biological relationships so this
is the simplest function prediction you
could possibly imagine with this so we
have a gene here gene alpha which is
ends up connected to node 2 with a high
weight relationship beta connected to
node 1 with a higher weight relationship
and gamma connected to node 3 with a
high weight relationship and then we
have a target gene so this is a gene
that for the purposes of this analysis
we basically ignored its function and
the target gene is connected to node 1
so we use a similarity just a
correlation of node weights to assign
pathways from from the closest gene so
it's a single nearest neighbor to the
target and so when you do this what
you're basically asking is is there
something encoded in these high weight
relationships that's actually indicative
of a pathway or function for these genes
and the answer is at least yes more than
random so if you do this on a per
thousand per muted networks you end up
with this distribution which never gets
you more than about five percent
accuracy if you actually look at the the
accuracy that we observed which was
about forty five percent is well outside
that so whatever this is learning you
know you could argue it's learning batch
effects or lab effects or other signal
but this would argue that it
least to some extent it's also learning
biological signal because you know we
would expect pathways to be sort of
universal across experiments if you just
do correlation yeah so if you just do
correlation it basically just identifies
operons and so operons tend to have the
same function so consequently if you
just do correlation it gets good
performance if you hold out operons
basically correlation falls apart and
this does not fall apart to the same
extent I mean it's still upper on signal
is definitely there and so basically I'm
going to sort of do the sort of magic of
an approach where we took all the stuff
we put it in the oven and now we're
getting out the complete bit so I want
to talk about some of the ways we can
use this for networks but if you have
questions about this the paper is
published all the source code for this
is online we do go in and show that you
can actually identify basically neural
network features associated with
specific processes you can then perturb
those processes in new experiments where
you're specifically trying to change a
single note to change a specific node
and that you actually can change this
node and so we've done quite a bit of
experimental characterization to font to
show the signals captured by this are
actually biologically relevant and that
we can change them in targeted
experiments and so you can read more
about that here if you want to I just
want to to get into a little bit of the
characteristics of the models that we
generate so basically not surprisingly
if you build a larger model so you have
more neural network nodes in it you
capture more pathways there's a little
bit of a ceiling here so there are some
pathways that we would say probably
aren't really capture Abba with
transcriptional data alone or with the
amount of transcriptional data that we
have or the diversity of transcriptional
data that we have right now and so in
pseudomonas these are keg pathways so
you know you can cover somewhere on the
order of 80 to 100 keg pathways with
with this type of approach and there's
some interesting kind of performance
characteristics so if we think about
capturing pathways not all pathways are
created the same right so some pathways
are going to be really broad signals
that sort of potentially characterize
the Compendium
so things like oxygen level or other
signals others are sort of more subtle
signals that might be perturbed in a few
experiments or might have a more subtle
gene expression pattern we see this as
well so if you look at something like
oxidative phosphorylation this is
essentially how significantly the
pathway ends up captured by nodes in a
net of in an adage model of a given size
and this is increasing the model size so
for oxidative phosphorylation the
smaller networks actually sort of
capture it more specifically and then
you can see the signal kind of drops off
as you get to larger networks conversely
for things like T racine metabolism ER
flagellar assembly there's basically
this pattern where you know I've added
more nodes I'm capturing more distinct
signals and at some point I get to to a
number of signals where I can capture
these types of pathways and so it's
important to think about you know at
this point if you're building an adage
model you really need to think about
sort of the granularity of signal that
you want to detect we can also use this
to get it networks so instead of
thinking about this as a model where we
can identify whether or not a pathway is
active in a given sample we can actually
think of it as a way to identify
similarity between genes so thinking
analogous to the the pathway prediction
approach that I mentioned before what
you do is for every gene you know you've
got these weights and you can just
calculate a correlation between genes
for the weight vectors so basically how
similar are my weights to to any other
gene and if you do this what you get is
a network that actually does a really
nice job of reflecting function so in
this case we're looking at similarity in
the adage model and it ends up
reflecting functional similarity quite
well so this is the network showing the
genes that were most connected in the
adage model we basically took this as a
spreadsheet handed it to our
collaborators because the gene ontology
annotations were not complete enough and
had our collaborators go in and pick
what if they had to name one category
for what that gene did what would it be
and so they picked these I think it's 14
categories along the bottom as well as
the black ones which are unknown and and
so they assigned a function to this sort
of spreadsheet of genes we went back and
mapped it on to the force directed
layout and what we see
is that in general the the genes end up
sort of segregating by function so it
looks like you know in addition to the
kind of analysis we did before for
pathway prediction you also get the same
sort of signal here going back to the
correlation question if you do this with
correlation because this is a bacterium
with jeans and operons that are all code
transcribed you basically just end up
with a poor on balls and and so the
largest connected component is
essentially the largest operon because
you don't get the sort of cross upper on
connectivity and I think this goes back
to something that actually Anastasia
found in her talk which is that if you
look at the bio grid genetic interaction
network you know the genetic
interactions alone give you a certain
network but the correlation over the
genetic interactions is actually
potentially a more meaningful measure of
at least in their case function above
and beyond gene expression correlation
and stuff like that what is it getting
so it's capturing gene expression
correlation but it does a really nice
job so if there's sort of really strong
correlation it's going to collect it
collapses that pretty efficiently into
like a single neural network node so if
you just do a linear correlation
basically that signal ends up swamp
another signal in this case like those
really trivial signals just get
collapsed and so it's sort of a it's a
sort of dimensionality reduction
approach like pca RI CA which of course
will come up in a few slides
yeah under different types of
experiments yes yes um so you break down
the thousand samples so I was with you
until the function prediction part yeah
okay I could actually took out those
slides somewhere on the order it depends
how big you want your network to be but
somewhere on the order of about 500
samples you end up being able to do a
pretty good job of capturing things that
are like pathway scale resolution so
like the 300 no dish neural network
notes yeah so we have that I just took
the slides out yeah yeah so if you have
so if you want like networks that
capture like the 50 largest signals in
the data you know you need something
like 200 ish 250 samples if you want to
get to like pathways type features you
really need something that's more on the
order of 500 samples so okay so this is
thinking so and also going back to to
mention a little bit more on that too
you know this is looking this is built
from a single run of this this deep
model and so yeah this neural network
model and so you know you can imagine
this is like okay I've got something
hidden underneath so I've got this you
know stone that's got some carving on it
and it's hidden underneath and all I've
got is the paper on top and I basically
taken graphite and done like one sweep
across that and so whatever angle I kind
of go at I captured just that type of
feature so you know we could do this
thinking about it sort of the stability
analysis where instead of you know just
doing one of these we do a bunch of
these and so we've now done that so this
is the follow on paper so my student
developed this ensemble approach so it's
an ensemble of these neural networks
which is net which we call a adage
basically you can train some number of
models we we generally training about
100 for each model you get nodes you can
then identify similarity between nodes
within and across models and then you
can collapse those to a single node and
so for the purposes of comparison we're
actually collapsing we've taken models
of a certain size
then we've collapsed them back down to
two num number of clusters that matches
that so we can actually do a direct
comparison so you only get if you get
300 nodes in your individual models yes
you're going to train you know hundred
of them so you're gonna have 30 thousand
nodes but at the end of the day you have
to collapse that back down to 300 nodes
for comparison so it's a yeah yeah so we
were looking for things that were
consistent across you know different
initializations and so I'm not sure a
deeper architecture is necessarily going
to give you that it might even get
potentially more sensitive to the
initialization I was supposed to give
you a different level of abstraction
over the original yeah so we wanted the
same level of so we yeah so we wanted
the same type of resolution but we
wanted to focus on the things that were
consistent across many runs so we were
really trying to sort of more like the
stability analysis they think been
talked about yesterday we are at it yes
the size of the kidney yeah so we varied
the size of this hidden layer in the
first paper we used 50 neural network
nodes actually because our collaborators
were going in by hand and annotating
because the annotations were so poor
we've actually the pathway annotations
stuff has led us sort of automate that a
little bit I mean we know we're
basically we know that pathway
annotations are not a great way to go
because they're just so limited in the
system and so you know we use them but
but view them kind of skeptically but
yeah now we're training things on the
sort of 300 scale yeah
it seems that activation function that
yeah so this is sigmoid
I think it would be a different signal I
think it would capture a different
signal yeah yeah so we actually like
this so we also like this for a
different reason which is that this the
sigmoid activation likes to capture
features that are sort of generally
bimodal or at least multimodal and so
we're interested in potentially one day
using these as biomarkers and so if you
have a feature you want to use as a
biomarker the multi modality is really
nice because it's easier you don't have
to pick like a cut off in the middle of
a normal distribution for where to draw
a line you usually get pretty clean
separation so yeah so we've been going
with sigmoid but you can swap it out and
definitely capture different things so
so basically the sea adage approach
which if you just use correlation to
combine the nodes it's better than a
single model if you use this e adage
approach that in the interest of time I
will skip the mech in this the the
details behind it's a little bit better
I'm going back to the initial example of
sort of pathways that kind of drop out
as you add more nodes when you do 'edit
you don't really see this to the same
extent so these are signals that are
showing up somewhere across runs and to
the extent that they still end up
getting collapsed we also don't tend to
see a performance drop in the things
that you know that we're getting well
captured at the large network size so we
think basically this increase is caught
you're basically getting by capturing
pathways that are sort of evident at a
little bit different levels of sort of
model resolution and the ica pc a
comparison since i figured that would
come up so this is if you just think
about sort of how well these things are
capturing pathways again you know all
the caveats on the the challenge of
pathways in this sort of not well
annotated organism we see that the e
adage approach is capturing more of them
we've also gone back and looked actually
in the first paper we looked at
experiments and we found that if you do
the new experiments you end up with
better performance if you're using a de
jazz so that was an adage comparison as
opposed to pca or ica for reasons i can
go into and Q&A if you if you want more
details but what I really want to
mention is that you know our goal of
doing this is not just a catalog of
pathways that are there so
there's lots of different ways you can
do function prediction and catalog the
pathways so we're really interested in
going beyond that and helping biologists
basically get at mechanism so I like
this quote from Elizabeth Blackburn it's
basically you know I didn't want to sort
of build a catalog I really want to know
how things work and we're really
interested in that too so we've been
thinking about how once you have this
model but that captures this variability
how do we actually put it to use in the
most effective possible way and one of
the things that we've been thinking
about is sort of pathway style analysis
so something like ingenuity pathway
analysis where in our case you know
we're looking at so in ingenuity you can
find like a fold how much a pathway has
changed across an experiment here we're
looking at how much a neural network
node has changed across an experiment so
you've probably seen volcano plots of
fold change for four genes this is the
exact same thing except instead of jeans
these are the neural network nodes and
we use a pareto selection scheme because
we don't like gating on significance and
so we care about things that either
change a lot or that are highly
significant once we do this if you
combine it with the networks what you
get at the end of the day is this sort
of pathway style analysis of a new
experiment so this is an RNA seek
experiment where we knocked out the
transcription factor anr and looked at
its downstream consequences it's pretty
well known that an R regulates
denitrification and so basically this
green here is essentially the change in
denitrification after the knockout what
was kind of cool in this is this quorum
sensing group up here so these are a
bunch of genes involved in quorum
sensing and so concurrent actually with
doing this analysis of paper came out
talking about showing that anr actually
regulates quorum sensing through these
aunt jean's so that's good in bed but so
but it was a kind of nice validation of
at least this style of approach we also
want to highlight just to give you a
more concrete idea of the lack of
annotations in the system so what I did
in this figure is actually colored in
all of the nodes that had a keg
annotation in the middle and so you can
if you look carefully there's basically
these guys up here which are molybdenum
and then this one an R Gean here and so
there are five genes in this that had a
keg annotation so if you're using
something like
gse a or one of these other methods you
know your gene set is so limited that
you would never pull out either of these
signals and so I think it's really
important for these organisms you know
when we move away from yeast and human
and mice to really focus on how can we
develop methods that can work if our
annotations aren't there because this is
a system that biologists actually
understand really well so our
collaborator looks at this and right
away says ok I'm changing
denitrification and quorum sensing so
it's not that the knowledge isn't there
it's just that we haven't curated it and
so so this is really an area focus for
our group we also have been looking at
sort of where can you do this so what
type of organisms could you build one of
these networks for so if you think about
this and looking at so this is an
analysis of array Express from something
like September of last year when I had a
grant due basically the number of
organisms that have data at that point
was around 2500 different organisms now
we can't build an adage model for an
organism that has one sample but if you
think about organisms that have 500
essays which is where we think our
method works at that point we were just
above 150 different organisms there's no
way we're going to get curation
communities together for these hundred
and fifty different organisms to curate
to the extent that we've done for for
yeast and humans and in addition to
methods we actually build web servers so
we have a web server that we're building
for this hope to have the pseudomonas
pilot ready by the middle of the summer
and then we're planning to get one
together that covers those hundred and
fifty organisms by early next year I
want to use my last like one minute to
give a shout-out to the research
parasite community so so this is a paper
from New England Journal earlier this
year the branded people who basically do
data analysis with data that's not their
own as research parasites which I really
hated personally because this is
basically us although I would argue
maybe we're research mutualists because
we we actually give biologists the tools
to go back and reanalyze their data but
in any case you know I thought that it
was really important that we as a
community really maybe own this term and
so I sent an email to the organizers of
PS be saying that what we really need is
a way to recognize excellent
contribution
the secondary analysis rigorous
secondary analysis of data so i just
want to mention we we are approved now
to have research parasite awards which
I'm calling the parasites so if you've
seen the Oscars or the Emmys this is the
the data science equivalent there's some
selection criteria the website will be
coming up soon we have a junior parasite
so for a trainee and sustained
parasitism for those who who have been
around a little bit longer I just want
to finish mentioning that you know I
think the value of research parasites is
avoiding the situation that this quote
puts us in which is basically you know
the things that we really are certain
about this is the chance where we can
use data to push back on that and so we
really need to value that this quote is
a perfect example because it turns out
it's attributed to Mark Twain but it's
really hard to find any documentation
that he actually ever said or wrote it
so it's probably misattributed which is
just beautifully ironic okay so I want
to just thank really quickly the people
involved in this work gia tan who's
listed up at the top there is a grad
student in the lab who did basically all
the adage research Matt and dong bo are
programmers who are building the adage
web server collaborators so the
experiments that the rna-seq experiment
I showed you and all the experiments
validating the adage models biology that
I didn't show you that are in the paper
we're done by Jack Hammond Ind Deb
hogan's lab we are shameful users of
public data shameless users I should say
a public data so people who follow the
rules and put it up there we couldn't do
it without you images are creative
commons other than Calvin and Hobbes and
people who give us money thanks Ron so
first of all when I just stopped and
getting
what is not on my own one of these Ben
Grauer describing himself as a scavenger
yeah yeah it's a little more positive at
least anyway ah if you just the collapse
they offer off yeah classical tools like
clustering won't you get essentially the
same result um I'm not sure so you're
saying if you basically collapse things
that are documented operons you know
calculate an aggregate summary statistic
and then cluster over those um see what
is there okay so just the date go yeah
so I think the analysis across networks
of different size suggests that you
probably won't get the same answer if
you just collapse the operons and then
cluster over that so otherwise you know
what you would expect would be just as
if that were the case you would expect
for all terms like a steady increase in
the more nodes you add the more the more
often you capture that pathway so I
don't think I don't we did not directly
test that but I the evidence we have I
would say suggests that probably you
would not get the same answer with that
yeah so actually the yeah so the first
use of this so gia applied it to breast
cancer biopsy data back in actually a
couple years ago we published it at PSB
I would say you know I think it
basically what we show is you know it
learns things like stromal infiltration
and tumor normal status and it basically
learns all the things you expect it to
learn to me the value of the
unsupervised approach is much higher
when you get to these organisms that
basically we can't hit with any other
method and so so I would say yeah I mean
we tried it we kind of it was an initial
validation but breast cancer biopsies
will also have the issue that we
couldn't really perturbed them well so
then we wanted to go to the use case
that we sort of envisioned it being best
in so the thing that's like you know an
organism that's used to study this case
biofilms and other systems and then sort
of really show it like in the situation
where we really envision it being used
so I guess I'd say we've done a little
bit of it but then we sort of moved on
yeah so so we don't do best correction
because in a lot of cases the batch
information is not available so we're
basically just downloading the publicly
available data that people have uploaded
and if you take a look at the
annotations so we actually had grad
students in Deb's lab go in and try to
annotate just some sort of standard
stuff across the entire collection of
experiments and it's amazing how sparse
that spreadsheet is so we just do not I
don't think we have the information I
mean someone somewhere probably has this
information in some excel spreadsheet
that's on their computer named like
final final you know something seven but
it's not available to us yeah so let me
talk resale network when you talk to the
human experts would it be any better to
also give them kind of fake network to
avoid confirmation bias yeah so I love
the idea of giving them a fake network
um so okay so there's a couple ways we
could fake the network so one way to
fake the network would be to basically
take the genes that were that we're sort
of differentially expressed in their
study pull out from the same network a
completely different set of genes so
basically randomize the gene expression
measurements and do the same thing
saying we had from the biologists yeah
so I would say I've never seen anyone do
it I love the idea so we're building the
web server so I guess we could do it a
couple ways so one is you put in your
results and then you get a network back
and sometimes it's real and sometimes
it's random I'm not sure our users would
like that yeah
unless you the audience of that
editorial a better um I mean I could
imagine so we could put like a check box
that would basically say okay now give
me a random Network yeah and no he
stayed up yeah oh yeah Foundation said
other like the overpaid a validation set
to write for IPA Oh for a lot of high
tea yeah people now actually ID noise to
the meditation beta yeah so we actually
we do run an experiment in our in a
class that I teach or we give students I
guess this is still on so all the future
students of this class will know what we
do if they so so we basically give
students a data set and then we also get
we give them two data sets and we tell
them they need to build a model to
predict something and in one of them
we've randomized the labels just to test
overfitting yeah I love the idea of
building it into the web server to
basically get a sanity check um I think
I would do it by randomizing the gene
levels I think we have to give
biologists the option to turn it on or
not because other ways too yeah almost a
hundred percent because Keith Beverly
from md anderson he does forensic
automatics yeah he's talked about on
youtube he said this biologists can
always find what they want in the data I
mean just give them a random set of
teens they're gonna say so he has this
example which I totally believe said he
did someone else's microarray analysis
for some lab and he didn't want so the
teens are facing aguenta the first time
didn't know so he gave it to the lab
that's how this is great you know we
found a lot of the genes that we know
are involved in the sky cancers thank
you and then I come to this later and
realize
teens the set the teen said that he said
it was completely wrong he was just
really embarrassed he sent a new sense
oh I'm sorry the preset wrong you know
this is the new set no one would prove
said you got evo x so this is even
better yeah there's so complex now so
that you always come find what you want
to see in any set of genes yeah I mean
so for me right this is not like I build
a network and then I like I build a
differential expression analysis and
that's where it ends so I would say I
think that's where it starts so then you
need to to to actually so the the aunt
jean's you know that wasn't the end
right that was the starting point for a
whole series of experiments testing you
know if I if I modify these do I
actually get a downstream change so you
know I don't see it as like the end of
an experiment it's kind of the beginning
and that's what we're pitching it for is
more exploratory types approaches but
yeah I agree with both of your
sentiments that it would be really fun
okay thanks again